io lo so che voi non avete minimamente
fiducia nel sottoscritto e pensate che
tutto quello che faccia sia un click
bait perché non è vero che il titolo che
avete letto e la realtà e io devo fare
una reaction a sta roba assolutamente
perché esiste io non lo sapevo ve lo
giuro esiste la serie tv di fp uil se
non sto schio non ne avevo la minima
idea ho letto che è più o meno è costata
pochissimo quindi non è gay che sia
chissà che però l'hanno fatta cioè la
serie tv di happy with lei non lo sa ma
come ho fatto a non saperlo episodi uno
sono introvabili gli episodi pensavamo
paga talmente poco sta serie per farla
che non mancheranno pubblicati però un
po in giro se riuscito a trovare
qualcosa vediamo sono curiosissimo come
voi giuro perché non ho idea di che cosa
avrà un quadro della capitale tripoli
[Musica]
ogni tanto stop per spiegarvi la
situazione è detto benvenuti alla
cittadina delle sedi del mito perché è
una cittadina felice da tutti quanti si
divertono infatti ci sarà la gente però
va bene sì ma ci racconterà delle storie
se ascoltiamo molto bene le sentiremo da
happy meal scritto coi pezzi di cobain
non è family friendly questa serie forse
c'è un motivo se sparita per ove c'è un
orecchio che vola
mi sa veramente di trash ma allo stesso
tempo di epicità incredibile di ragazzi
nonno jacques number one
ovviamente dietro c'è perché mi
aspettavo che il personaggio principale
per la stampa di più però va bene lui si
è salvato
stavo scherzando però bello che
l'orecchio l'orecchio un po come la
piuma di forest campo non so se avete
visto che vogliamo però mio dio non
poteva mancare lei è successo a fare
stregone
non sto capito cosa è successo
probabilmente almeno in parte
ma si va bene signori video per tutte le
famiglie
mamma mia è una sola
l'incrocio tra happy meals e happy tree
friends lo conoscevo che mostra però non
ci credo che i miei preferiti ci sono
anche loro
by you say you che l'hanno ammazzata e
lavoro che pensavo lui è triste realtà
quindi vuol dire che gli vuole bene
abbiamo finalmente scoperto non sarò mai
capito e normale che quelle spontanee
siano l'effetto del mondo e risposto no
doubt mai povero sto per vincere il
titolo padre dell'anno certo l'orecchio
è caduto come una fiaba bellissimo soft
ma attenzione alla gente mentre va bene
sono nato in quella casa dice tutto bene
quel che finisce bene come un gioco pena
l'applicazione cielo roland hanno
schivato come se niente fosse col
bicchiere di vino però lo sapevo che
c'era un po resca
mamma mia ragazzi complimenti
complimenti dal primo episodio della
serie chi è più in su che forrest gump
alla citazione e top veramente in crisi
e bellissimo questa è episodi uno
ragazzi devi passare all'episodio 2 apr
[Musica]
già la partenza dice tutto con la maglia
morti ce la presenta dell'incidente al
parco divertimenti delle 200 e non s'è
pisciato addosso appena detto che la
percentuale in realtà e 301 per cento
sicuramente io non ci andrei però è se
mi immergo le mie gambe si
trasformeranno in una in una colonna
pinna tipo io credo che abbia detto non
lo so prima di continuare di fare una
piccola premessa vi ricordate il video
haters in italia questa persona qua
later dietro si in italia media non
aveva più avanti è la tipa dice sì lui
si butta giustamente la keibler non
esisteva e style è annegato credo
infatti auto tranquillo beh non c'era
sangue comunque loro sono dei tester
loro testano le giostre capito ok questo
non avevo capito sta roba è sta
salutando suo figlio che ovviamente
portato da un'altra persona e non si sa
come mai lui questo bando che non esce
mai dal seggiolino trovano il mega vita
però vabbè
per la parte di lui non mi sembra tanto
sicura però c'era già la fila di grinta
e formatasi consiglio site
non so cosa sta succedendo
vabbè dall'altro la gente sarà fatta al
bagno tranquillamente con nonno che era
sdraiato nel nulla da giusta ma è giusto
comunque ovvio lei ha perso qualcosa da
mangiare si butta nell'acqua per
prenderlo come se fosse non lo so tipo
di vitale importanza e ci finisce con il
2 enrico chi si è salvato non è morto
sabato non è stata la mia più grande
idea ai via va bene sono gravi ma si
chiama e proprio one man who kinks non
ho capito una sega del discorso finale
però un bellissimo orologio e stanno
andando a comprare dei fan
cakes che sono del libro ha sempre un
lieto fine direi che siamo pronti
all'ultimo episodio di oggi perché sono
molto corti ma meritano
facciamo quindi partire l'ultimo ragazzi
non so non so cosa aspettarmi prova bene
ma va vano a questo si chiama friday
night races le gare sera la sera poi
l'altra muro ha detto chi è che vincerà
e le altre macchie che sopra vivrai un
po meglio
e vero ci sono enti contro papa uk la
ciccione ciccione
noi va bene se no molto a farci anche
altra gente sono molto fiducioso la
prima morte non era niente di che i
ragazzi tranquillo ho visto di peggio
ok questo gioco sporco e un senso che
schifo così successo proprio come se
fissato addosso ecco gli occhi che come
al solito fa il trascinatore ma c'è che
viene trascinato si stanno intanto non
ho trovato un amico come sempre ragazzi
sta roba non è un senso ci sono ancora
steve contro mi è rimasta poca gente in
realtà è eco sembra una rata è disputato
sbagliato schifo in un ciampi ha visto
che strano che noi che steve non abbiano
perso mai un ragazzo come un mezzo per
lui non ha un nome invece
sai cosa che sta succedendo lì oh mio
dio
povero gli uffici e sempre eh vabbè alla
fede tutto il papà di yuki nel modo o
nell'altro e vince sempre senza il
figlio non so ma le pare la testa è
arrivata seconda giustamente e poi
celina lui eredi happy wheels non sta
ricordando queste cose che non ho capito
dicono che ho detto va bene sta
immaginando se ci fosse un apocalisse
zombie su happy with non so ben capendo
però non ha un senso questa è quindi
ragazzi questo questo era ecco come non
detto
il finale quasi finale popolazione uno
in meno giustamente mi è piaciuto non ho
capito una sega perché non c'erano i
sottotitoli quindi io l'inglese
onomastico fino a un certo punto diciamo
che lo mastico ma mi fanno male i denti
quindi non so bene come prenderlo però
bello cioè nel senso è bellissimo fatto
bene cioè per quanto hanno speso
probabilmente un euro fatto bene
complimenti quindi ragazzi questa sera
la serie teoria dei primi tre episodi
della serie tv di apv se non ha molto
senso in realtà però però bello militava
una visita al mese nessuno di voi lo
sapeva che esiste ma neanche io l'ho
scoperto per caso prima che facevo
zapping letto ma com'è possibile
ho dovuto vedere queste robe un incrocio
tra è più invisa ovviamente april france
quindi c'è sempre di ep in mezzo alla
gente quanto squartando si le cose c'è
sempre un che di felice non so perché
spero che vi sia piaciuto era un po poco
family friendly ma andava vice dai non
poteva non vedere non fare la reaction a
star of sales e dove visse iscrivetevi
schiacciate anche la campanellina
presagio nati sui nuovi video che escono
e noi come sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video bei ragazzi
[Musica]